how are you handling the controversy how
are you and when you've made the
comments about Taylor Swift and the
Kardashians when you spoke out honestly
about how you felt and things were taken
out of context how have you managed it
well I think the funny thing is to me
that the way that I felt honestly about
the situation was that I didn't care or
have an opinion and so when I was
assigned an opinion I just felt like I
wanted to back away and completely
reexamine however I respond in the media
to everything which is if you don't have
an opinion apparently now I'm just going
to walk away like a rude person it
should be like or do you know what
smilin not sure but um so I never
thought that I would be that taken out
of contact yeah well you do have a
chance to set the record straight if you
would prefer yeah but I think that's it
right no I think all i have to say is um
I I don't know anything about the
situation I don't care about the
situation and I don't want to comment on
the situation